[Applause]
there's a fight that i'm sure
people are starting to mention now we're
huge fans of israel out of sonia on the
show we've had izzy on the show
that's our homie i know that's your
homie um
there's one division between you guys
you are massive for 170
and izzy is not big for 185
is that a potential fight
for you or is he is that a potential
fight
because i know you're both competitors
and that is a bad [ __ ] over
there right
absolutely what do you think about that
we are
we're both competitors and uh and don't
be fooled by that izzy's deceptively big
for oh yeah yeah i always tell people
he's deceptively big he's tall yeah yeah
he has strong legs and he moves well and
um and
and striking just unreal unreal at the
the rate and the pace that he's able to
see strikes and adjust and react to them
is next level yeah and um you know
if i was if i wasn't who i was that
would be
a test that i would oh my god i would i
would i would salivate over
but um that's my brother man and um i
just i can see
myself getting in there
and mentally preparing to fight is i
couldn't see that
um and i this is a a quote that i've
said time and time and time again
it's uh i'd rather see two nigerians
with belts
than one nigerian with two belts so you
know that's not a fight i'm looking at
okay that being said what if
izzy came out and said that your family
can't cook joel off rice
what if he said your job price is trash
would you have to avenge that
i would call them up asap and uh
we gotta have we gotta have a
conversation about that
we need to have a cookoff yeah i'll say
it
um you know i i just i can't picture
i just can't picture it right now no i
love that i think that's great
and uh i think it's cool you see
fighters there have been fighters
throughout history that have done it
they've just been such close friends
that they wouldn't want to do it and
also you guys are fortunate enough to be
in financial situations where
you're not uh needing that fight in
order to feed your family etc
uh but these pipe dreams are always cool
interesting thing
um about about what you're going through
right now which i think is always really
interesting is like you hear like guys
like george st pierre they think about
coming back right they're like oh yeah
i might come back for that khabib fight
he's not mentioning coming back for that
oh smith fight
is he no i i just
i i'm starting to slowly my
i hope for that fight is starting to
dwindle yeah and um
it just doesn't make sense for him it
doesn't
uh to go to still have your name
attached like
look at how i'm slowly elevating and
building myself
and his name still attached to it so
that's that's what you want once you
cement it and you put yourself in that
place
there's no point in risking it and he
he's
that's the one thing that i i do love
about george
um that we i i believe we we think
similarly on and we agree on is that
he's honest with himself
he's very very honest with himself as
far as
stating what he's capable of what he
thinks and
and and just the facts
fighters of today are better than
fighters of yesterday right
and fighters of tomorrow will be better
than fighters of today
it's a fact um and and george is honest
about that
and and i that's one thing that i i
commend him for
and i i love that he's honest about
because
a lot of people like to make that debate
who joe you just george you versus
george or
or me versus matt hughes i would kill
matt hughes yeah
you know it's just it's just it's just
different
it's different it's not that matt hughes
wasn't a great might he was a
pioneer i put him on the mat my rushmore
of welterweights
right he's great but you think about the
time and you think about
the way mma was being fought at that
time you know a lot of fighters had one
one skill that they were very good at
the horse gracie very jiu jitsu
specialist
to where now you get guys who come in
with
two skills boxer wrestler yeah and they
start taking over that's the matt hughes
error
and now you have guys that can do
everything matt hughes
doesn't know what a calf kick is like
imagine you
you know i gave matt hughes about four
cap kicks forget it that's like done
yeah it's different so you know that's
just a difference in in
to where it makes it very very hard to
really say oh who's the best but
gsp that was that's a fight that uh if i
still got if i got a call tomorrow i i i
don't know if i
i wouldn't believe it you can't yeah
yeah let's go george signed
let's freaking do this all right i
absolutely would do it i'd be jazzed up
for that one but i just don't think
that's gonna happen
we don't want to take too much of your
time but i do have another question what
do you think the best because you
brought it up what do you think the best
skill set is
for the modern day fighter because i've
been looking at a lot of guys who
came up with wrestling backgrounds and
then learn striking
and it seems like that's the most
well-rounded
if they can get the striking down if
they don't learn the striking then they
can struggle
but what what do you think that elite
recipe is for the mma fighter today
it's hard to deviate from from facts
and the fact is let's think about it you
watch a street fight go down
yeah right now okay you watching it
boom these guys are fighting think about
a fight there's only three positions
that a fight could be
both could be standing up trading
punches
one guy on top of the other guy on the
ground beating him up
or reversed the other guy on top of the
ground beating him up three positions
that a fight could take place
yeah and two-thirds of a fight that of
those positions are on the ground
yeah yeah so as a wrestler that means i
have the ability to control and dictate
where that fight takes place so
if you're a judiciary specialist and you
you want to
submit me you got to be able to take me
down if you can't take me down
in my life as in my last fight how are
you going to use that jiu jitsu
yeah yeah and and as a striker
if you're a great boxer or kickboxer and
you want to keep me standing and use it
and i can take you down how are you
going to use that skill
you just can't so it's very hard to deny
the fact that
wrestling is probably the single most
important
aspect of mixed martial arts right now
um yeah it is cool to see
see that evolve okay i want to do a
little lightning round you know we do a
little light ring around when we have
special guests on okay
um here we go this is gonna be quick all
right
mozvidal said that you had pillows for
hands was that because
they made him go to sleep
i guess that's something you gotta ask
him but
i would say yes that that's bro that's a
yes
okay kamar you are basically royalty in
nigeria right now
can you ask those nigerian princes to
stop emailing me
[Laughter]
while you add it tell them stop emailing
me
okay this is a serious one all right
daniel cormier or jake
paul who wins oh my god that's not easy
jake right i know i know i i honestly i
thought dc was going to smack him over
the weekend
not
[Laughter]
so you see available is espn
the mouse the mouse is doing good for
for dc
all right man before you leave who you
want next bro who do you want next
um i don't i'm that's
like think about it i've been through
them all
i'm trying to think who else is there at
the
at the end of the day now what it comes
down to is i like having fun now
i like being able to go into the fight
and know that i'm having fun now
and um so in order for me to do that
someone's got to motivate me george
motivated me
by i mean it was the perfect excuse six
weeks
oh this guy can do this and and george
sold the fight well i mean he he's
talking oh this guy
doesn't hit hard at all i mean he wasn't
blessed with the machoness
to be able to hurt someone with his
hands
you know and uh those things just kind
of stick in my head it's like oh
word yeah that's how you feel
okay so these are things that motivate
me to want to go in there and have fun
and right now just looking at the guys
you know no one there they're all just
kind of sitting around waiting on me to
pick them
for them to get a payday so i just want
someone to you know show me something
show me some good activity to where i'm
like
like oh [ __ ] that dude it's scary all
right i want him
to motivate me to to get off i'm
literally
the couch is right there i'm literally
on the couch all day today
waiting for my daughter to get off
school so when someone motivates me i'm
gonna get off this couch and uh
and we'll have fun again